lady gaga
stuns in custom Ralph Lauren she was
recognized at the National Board of
Review annual awards gala just means the
world to me
you know I've always wanted to be an
actress the character Ally that I play
in a star is born
you know she is nothing like me and I
really it was such a challenge to craft
her and to make her and to craft her
sound and how she would become and you
know I think what's so wonderful as I
don't feel rewarded just for my
performance but for the hard work that
was put in and and also to see bradlee
being awarded as Best Director and Sam
for Best Supporting Actor you know and I
couldn't be happier it's just wonderful
we all worked hard and I just want
everyone to know out there people of all
sexual identities you know that if you
work hard you can do anything you can
achieve anything the star is born
actress and her co-star Bradley Cooper
celebrated in a unique way no we went
home yeah we got something to eat we
both did the same thing
nothing like a bowl of sugar and that
golden glow I was happy as a clam
parties are lovely but it's really nice
to spend time with your closest friends
and your family and talk and reflect on
the work because you know without my
friends and my family I can't do what I
do and you know I really love spending
that quality time with them as for the
evenings keepsakes gaagaa has plans for
both her dress and second Golden Globe I
believe I do get to keep it and it will
be in my archive
[Music]
you